on n'aura pas une miette des recettes
exécutés par les chefs lui aussi va
bientôt présenter sa recette à ses
idoles inchy parmentier de patates
douces
en fait c'est emma thompson et de ses
cuisines elle cuisine et est dans le
bourg de saint pierre et plus je crois
que ça m'a inspiré
moi j'adore cuisiner le cépage cessé
depuis tout petit l'amour de la cuisine
créole c'est ce qui rassemble
aujourd'hui les participants de ce grand
show culinaire
douze chefs autant de plats proposés
autour de produits locaux tous agrémenté
d'une touche de rom bat l'alphabet
caramélisées aux fruits de la passion
vanille de wall ou bio et fin bon vieux
saint james
ensuite on va incorporer un espuma donc
si nous de caramel beurre salé et
vanille bio de boileau et un petit chris
pine citron vert et chocolat blanc c'est
très frais en bouche et puis on sent
bien la banane qui a été légèrement
pour aider l'alliance avec notamment la
vanille c'est très très délicieux et
face à ces chefs reconnus comme orlando
cette chaîne de sainte lucie les fins
gourmets affluent pour assister au
spectacle
tu n'as c'est très simple c'est du thon
c'est savoureux et c'est facile à
cuisiner
j'ai voulu expérimenter l'association
c'était sympa des chefs étoilés et lé
meilleur chef de la caraïbes réunis pour
mettre en valeur la gastronomie et le
rhum martiniquais à travers le créole
fudan roms l'union des métiers et des
industries de l'hôtellerie souhaite
dynamiser le secteur de la restauration
[Applaudissements]